hey youtubers is charlie if you guys
haven't realized what everyone's running
around with their phones on the street
getting hit by cards Pokemon go just
launched and even though it's crashed
like three times since it launched it is
like one of the best ways to ruin your
life that suffer if you have absolutely
no idea what's going on Pokemon go is an
augmented reality Pokemon game so it's a
really good excuse if you have been
playing pokemon for awhile or you don't
want to buy a nintendo device just to
use your phone download it on the iTunes
or the android store and it's pretty
self-explanatory like you find new
pokemon by walking around on the street
like it uses map locations for Pokemon
so like right outside my apartment at
the cross street they're like a couple
Pokemon just there randomly so instead
of using other pokémons to fight that
like to capture them like you
traditionally would in Pokemon you
actually just throw the ball at them you
just like swipe your thumb on your phone
it's kind of buggy right now but there
are certain types of locations tied to
certain types of Pokemon like if you go
near a body of water they're supposed to
be more water pokemon if you run into
another random Pokemon person on the
street you can't fight them unless
you're in a gym like you can't just do
it anywhere the things that are really
important in addition to having the
phone it's actually like the gameplay is
relatively simple once you get the thumb
swiping down like there's a target that
appears when you're trying to catch one
it's just a basic data connection with
access to GPS it's kind of like if
Google Maps had a baby with a Pokemon
game that's kind of what the augmented
reality looks like so it's a really good
excuse to tell your friends that you're
totally going outside to exercise when
you're really looking for pokemon but
you actually do have to run around
because there aren't any really good
websites that have started tracking
really specific pokemon locations really
like the fastest way you could possibly
go around would be getting like a
motorcycle something really agile like a
bicycle but you can walk around to like
even just like around my block around my
apartment there are still a lot of
regular pokemon but if you're looking
for rares or legendaries you probably
have to go for a bit of a hike so
there's a whole bunch of stuff going on
today like there's a whole lot of really
serious stuff going on today so if
you're looking for like a really fun way
to distract yourself or just destroy
your free time this summer pokemons go
is a completely acceptable way to
embarrass yourself by tripping in the
middle of the street when nothing is
nearby the game's still pretty fresh
those servers are getting really pounded
like it just launched most places around
the world
so of course servers are going to be
down every once in a while so don't be
surprised if you try to log in and it
gives you the middle finger just try
back again in a little while I'm not
really planning on doing gameplay videos
or anything like that for it just
because there's no really good screen
capture apps for your phone that don't
involve walking around with the giant
rig on your back that would be even more
embarrassing more embarrassing than
bumping into your adult friends trying
to catch pokemon in the middle of the
day when you should be at work let me
know if you guys have any funny stories
about Pokemon being at your workplace or
like somewhere where you go or a gym
being nearby with a bunch of just random
people trying to come in and catch them
there was actually a police station in
Australia that had a Pokemon nearby
people kept coming in to the police
station select the police chief had to
come out and be like dude people you do
not have to come inside the police
station to catch the Pokemon so give me
all your ridiculous Pokemon ghost
stories thanos collecting the infinity
gems really just looking for super rare
legendary Pokemon the flash season for
Pokemon multiverse edition last episode
ends with Barry getting trapped in his
own pokeball by the reverse-flash in
what I've actually found out is that you
don't actually need to be like right on
top of the location you just need to be
nearby it so like you don't have to be
standing right on top of the Pokemon to
try and catch it so like I live a couple
stories up in my apartment I didn't have
to go outside my apartment to try and
catch the Pokemon that were on my street
the game itself is free to play but
there are in app purchases for like
incense for helping you catch them lucky
eggs egg incubators lure modules so
there are things that you can buy with
money to help you catch pokemon but I
would recommend you try doing it with
that like I don't recommend people spend
a lot of money inside apps that's one of
the pitfalls of free apps like if you've
ever seen the freemium gaming episode of
south park that's like a really good
cautionary tale that in the magic
episode that's basically what's
happening today hardcore dude is
happening with Pokemon on the street but
it's also freemium making you wonder if
the Canadian devil works at Pokemon the
Pokemon itself is pretty fun but like
the last big interaction I had with the
franchise was on my game boy advance so
it was a long time ago I haven't really
kept up with the cartoons burn like the
video games where my point of access but
since I've been making YouTube videos
I've kind of been on a soft ban of
Nintendo products just because I don't
really like their policies with the way
a treat Nintendo content on YouTube so
this is just like a really fun game to
play that does not require that you buy
additional hardware but if you really
want to like of course there's like an
add-on that you can buy there's a
bluetooth Pokemon go plus it just helps
let you know when pokemon stuff is
nearby or when stuff is going on but you
don't have to buy that to play the game
like you could literally download the
app right now and play on your phone so
I would recommend you at least try it
out like a little bit it's kind of fun
it is a totally acceptable way to make a
fool of yourself today but what's going
to happen later tonight when i'm not
busy making an idiot of myself out on
the street is i'll be posting a new game
of thrones QA so be sure to subscribe to
get that there's a giveaway going on
right now announce the winner when i
post that so that should be up later
tonight well you guys wait for my next
video to post you can click here turn
what's going on behind the scenes on
spider-man homecoming and you can click
here for my store Ragnarok
behind-the-scenes video thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight